ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
- Jen Jillian podcasts we are back we
are good Street guests but now we're
back now we're about yourselves we can
make it
this episode's generally marked as is
brought to you by headspace get some
head space right now with a guided
meditation on the headspace app go to
head space.com slash generally try to
take ten program and do ten days of free
guided free guided meditation anywhere
you are shut them
thank you add space the other sponsor
this week is bowling branch guys all
your luxury bedding needs for affordable
prices go to there you that's a little
better
bowling branch calm use promo code Jana
Julian who was that I don't know sorry I
started messing with the audio jacks was
a bad idea
yeah 20% off when use promo code Jenna
DeLeon polar branch makes amazing
bedding the softest ever anything you
need huh put a ball and branch calm we
sleep on them all the time and then
except when we wash them and then that's
the worst day of all the days
yeah cuz I'm gonna be on yeah thank you
to our sponsors thank you sponsors so if
game we have a game today well first can
we talk about that we're having a
celebratory beverage right now because
we just spent so much time like redoing
our backyard and it came out amazing and
we're like we're happy and we spent the
bulk of the last two days going out and
getting stuff and assembling it and
putting it and cleaning out there but
it's kind of turned into a really
wonderful spot and I'm really proud of
it
yeah seriously we debated podcasting
outside because like sucked
yeah the a/c is really loud like knowing
no easy oh my god we turned off the 80s
a/c though while we both can't speak so
congrats on being in my club yes people
oh there's tons of stuff outside that
like there's construction there's birds
as the dogs and the squirrel that
[ __ ] squirrel our neighbor cut down
this giant ass branch today because
well kept running across it we're like
thanks fam yeah so you know you'll see
more vlogs out there now you'll see you
know I was hanging out Mars it's a
livable space it's so amazing and we
really really did it we did we invested
some time and some money into it because
we really feel like you know we
constantly feel like we want to like go
on little staycations for the weekend
whether it's like Big Bear or whatever
because it's just like a fresh place to
hang out outside or wherever and we
never do that here and so now we have
two [ __ ] hot outside in a system
where there's an umbrella for the show
you have an umbrella so you can go hang
out there and like use your phone
without going blind yeah and in the the
table we got doubles is like a mini fire
pits so we can sit out there at night
it's called awesome yeah enough of us
bragging about all right oh my god we
have a really cool I hope it's gonna be
really cool and fun I have high hopes
this game by the way I'm drinking
Firestone IPA they made a gluten free
[ __ ] incredible sake so um this was
suggested on my facebook and I was
laughing pretty hard because it's a
fantastic suggestion it was suggested by
Joe Bama for Rica on my facebook we're
gonna play a game called nuclear winter
yeah where you write down 20 people just
20 regular people occupations we did it
sorted by occupation and then you write
down I think we end up we wound up doing
21 actually as we added one wild card in
there but uh then you write down 20
characteristics so and in this hat we
have the characteristics and in that
fanny pack we have people people every
let I didn't realize they're both
findings but so what happens is you you
pair them up with each other randomly
and then you have to pretend that you're
in a bomb shelter that only houses us
and ten other people so these sometimes
good sometimes bad people are going to
be paired with sometimes good sometimes
bad characteristics we have to decide
who we're going to keep in our bomb
shelter with us to survive the
apocalypse nuclear winter hmm so so you
wanna get going
five we might pretty funky we're going
outside in our new backyard yeah no it
should not just peaches toy graveyard
anymore she is or anybody else have a
dog though that brings their toys
outside and leaves them out there and
ruins them thing great bring me toys
inside
you naughty you got kind of creative
with these characteristics and uh so
when we break we'll pick them and then
break and then assess yeah okay so then
we have to debate who we're gonna keep
and who we're gonna lose okay all right
I like that all right do you want to do
the characteristics oh yeah I'll do
characteristics all right make sure
they're random they're in a hat they're
random make sure that way how do I make
sure it's random don't look you can't
look like I'm here at you got one yeah
okay I'll read the person first and then
the characteristic so the first person
up for debate for our nuclear bomb
shelter is a nurse oh okay okay a nurse
who has four puppies that they will
bring with them whoo that's a good kid
right there okay so I'll put them
together there's these are gonna blow
away cuz that fans a nurse with know
they want the pet the fans pointed
towards me so you're safe Hey look at it
it's gonna blow away eternally you're
not gonna blow it hmm
but thank you also forgot to say actual
thank you to the person that suggests
this because this is [ __ ] exciting
I'm excited all right second person I'll
draw the occupation get in here are you
ready are you ready are you ready oh
okay supposed to get all that hot up in
here a ventriloquist
who is also a veteran zombie prepper oh
that's really good and oh that's
valuable though a veteran zombie prepper
is valuable yep
okay all right let's keep going I'm
already huh Julian come on
my name's King don't be in dramatic look
okay a chef
who choose with their mouth open oh
that's bad
that's that's not good okay all right I
mean it's ironic a little yeah but
whatever I'm gonna mix them all up want
to make sure they're good all right you
ready yep a horse just a horse a horse
who won't stop lighting their own farts
on fire a horse that won't stop lighting
their own farts on fire it's pretty
[ __ ] amazing heard you damn good but
like you could ride them for
entertainment all right we will debate
them later we'll debate Emily so we do
all 20 and then we pick 21 huh yeah
little bit you ready yeah are you ready
DVD BB EB become okay a pregnant woman
who is really sexy
oh it's I underlined it like a bunch
though it's really sexy you know this
could have gone so much worse a pregnant
woman because we had some people in here
that we shouldn't be calling sexy really
sexy all right my sexy prank that sly
cat thing right people have like that
fetish yeah I mean there's a fetish for
everything it's true it's true that
table is looking pretty damn high that
take yeah a horse that is really
sensitive okay all right a marine Oh a
marine that has a truck full of guns
food water and other supplies I'll bring
that's it definitely oh oh you know that
guy in your bomb shelter that's like an
easy way to survive right yeah that's a
good lay up we already know what we're
doing with that like how did those two
get together I don't know that's Kista
completely [ __ ] random sprig all
right you can't read yours until I read
minds
film a homeless person who insists on
having a cantar kumbaya sing-along every
night before bed that's actually pretty
good
oh okay insists on having a guitar
kumbaya sing-along every night every
single night every [ __ ] that every
single everyone got in a fight doesn't
matter tonight we're doing Kumbaya
that's right foreign people could be
starving to death and he's got to play
the guitar would be dead okay
a police officer what just a doctor
oh no we [ __ ] it up you got to put
this in here we got to shuffle it and
sir okay take another one please guys we
done [ __ ] up the masturbates at least
greater than or equal to eight times a
day and no one can ever say [ __ ] cuz
he's a cop
oh okay Oh guys guys greater to or
greater than or equal to eight times a
day so at least eight mm-hmm oftentimes
more mm okay all right a teacher quiz
scissors for him okay that's good how
does she teach the children hey kid oh
my god all right you don't want to be in
timeout oh my god hmm you [ __ ] you don't
we need I'm Irina don't cheat boy don't
a boy me boy if you don't okay all right
can you an architect who has a Mensa
brain okay famous actually Julian came
up with that one who has a Mensa brain
well what do you call it when you're
when your Mensa a member of Mensa but
you have a Mensa brain I mean I suppose
it's a prerequisite to being a member I
suppose I'm right too
I suppose Oh how many is that so far
that's ten ten all right we have ten
more to go or it better be good okay
thank you
Ethan h3h3 a pop star who sighs
complains and says well what are we
going to do now in every situation
believable well what are we gonna do now
like I would follow okay
we're gonna do came up with that
characters I noted it I came up with
both of us okay ready
you read it beforehand you cheated
that's not cheating cheater God you
can't do that that's double cheating you
already saw what it was I think this is
it you are Jillian Janice stop you're
making this worse than it is I think
this was it
60% a masseuse who makes an offensive
amount of the office references every
day gee I wonder who that was inspired
by I wrote that because I'm you know I
love you but it's a lot of office
references when we get married
my entire vows are going to be the
office reference was that an office
reference in and of itself are we gonna
walk down the aisle today in it forever
we're gonna escape and go on a cruise
and Niagara Falls and then come back to
the cruise okay then half later outs a
little boat goes under the foot gene you
have seen the wedding and the Agra sauce
is that the maiden in the mist or
whatever
no one from Rochester ready for our
wedding at Niagara Falls oh my god
no I'm gonna get all wet yeah I can't
wait to get all dress up and like put my
fake eyelashes on go get soaking wet
you'd be been beautiful Buffalo New York
you won't get wet married not even a
good side of the falls Canadians I'd
better do it-- you ignorant [ __ ] okay
anyways a botanist
okay who is also a severe and violent
alcohol
that's funny pairing like that that was
a wrench in [ __ ] look good they just
hate botany so much that he just [ __ ]
me got it every day he told me you just
got it [ __ ] take the edge off there's
like beautiful flowers everywhere and
holes in his wall everywhere he argues
with the plants all the time
ok pedophile wait what do we mess them
up we do we put two Patamon this isn't
our we did two pedophiles
no pedophile is a characteristic not a
Morrison sorry guys we keep [ __ ] up
it's probably peaches fault it is
sister alright alright sorry a convicted
felon by the way guys happy fourth of
July
today's the fourth of July oh yeah cuz
holy [ __ ] it took us this long yeah so
it's so the fourth yet but for you as
for happy for enjoy this treat as a 4th
of July celebration that's crazy we
forgot to say that in America Bay [ __ ]
America Bay independence of America
pendants alright I have a person
convicted felon first-degree murder who
thinks they're also a psychic that's
good oh okay I like that
okay all right can you imagine though
okay we'll talk about it later
is no keep it movin keep it movin bum oh
bum a lawyer who's also a rapist Oh God
a serial rapist serial rapist okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] is right these
people are [ __ ] all right ready
mm-hmm a mechanic's pedophile okay all
right okay okay fix cars and also touch
kids okay what I'm staying at ice
you you actually wrote I think my Roth
IRA mechanic it feels so weird
no does why is my beer spilling did I oh
because I moved it sideways I'm a
[ __ ] idiot
or did you put it down no I moved it
sideways to like get it under this thing
and that [ __ ] it up hmm well you
better drink it should chug it
mm-hmm you still got insurance you do
not you you did it I did now it's on the
chair and the whole thing about it
there's actually a blurb on Wikipedia
the beer that spelled on Julian's head
I'm such an idiot sideways Ireland the
mayor luckily is heavily addicted to
meth oh my god he's he's currently mayor
and he's also currently a meth addict
yeah cool welcome wherever we are
hmm Oh a doctor
okay soluable person who's triggered in
claustrophobic situations Oh God so
brutal cuz we're in a bomb shelter ah
[ __ ]
Oh men we're all gonna die of horrible
diseases here lies your penis okay yeah
a seven-year-old orphan who pretends
that they are a cat that's such a good
kind pretend that they're a cat yeah I
definitely don't want that orphan around
here they might be entertaining all
right we'll talk about it we'll get
there we get them we get there we'll get
there maybe we'll get there all right
you'd be a musically star who has two
invisible friends party Winkle and Olay
that they will be bringing with them oh
my god the worst person to have in your
box but not the worst like imagine them
just like
maybe a copay la they don't use their
labs like cell phone battery for
anything like they're the only one left
with okay last one
yeah a rocket scientist who doesn't stop
asking you to subscribe to their YouTube
channel this game is stressful for a lot
of reasons but I think the main reason
why it's stressful is because we're
stuck in this bomb shelter with no good
bedding but you could have good bedding
because you could get some Boleyn branch
sheets for your bed right now guys go to
Boleyn branch and check out their
selection of awesome sheets Boleyn
branch cuts out the middlemen that you
don't have to go to a store you know off
- I mean mattress stores sheets stuff
like really getting online haven't
shipped you are from Poland branch they
deliver incredibly quality materials
you'll sleep on it for the first time
and you'll realize like I mean how do
you describe like what the Boleyn branch
sheets are just the different level you
can't go back
risk-free for 30 nights you traveled 30
nights you don't like it get your money
back that's how that's how it works I'm
confident there yeah Boleyn branch just
go online a bowl and branch calm that's
bol and branch calm use products code
Jana Julian and get yourself some sheets
and then take a selfie on the sheets and
then send them to us because we want to
see your new sheets not be clothes
though yeah well any clothes send the
nudes to Jenna I'll take the clothes
buying the bedding from them is really
really good send me your nudes
I love you they care about you but no
free shipping guys and you know be
shipping they're so comfortable that
they've graced the beds of three former
US president presidents and countless
others yeah I didn't know that three
former US presidents have slept on Bolin
brunch guys that's greatness it's
actually yes that is cool
that is cool yeah 20% off with our code
anything you guys are getting sheets
towels blankets duvet covers everything
on the site 20% off when you use Jenna
Julian at bol and branch comm check it
out and let us know
what you think next sponsor guys
headspace I've talked so much about
headspace and how it really is something
that you can't replace right now like
the way that they make meditating very
easy and they obviously guide you
because it's got a meditation just to
take you out like I can't tell you how
many times where I just want I like pop
in my headphones and I'm like 10 min 10
minutes that goes by like in your normal
day 10 minutes goes by so fast but if
you just stop for a second it feels like
a great long relaxing 10-minute break
that a lot of times whether you're you
know whether you're at work or you're
you're doing work or you're with
whatever you can take ten minutes and
turn off and have guided meditation with
the headspace out to help you really
reduce stress and anxiety those are two
real things that a lot of people go
through including myself headspace is a
wonderful tool for your daily life you
can try it 10 days for free guided
meditation you just pop your headphones
into your phone tablet computer wherever
you are go to headspace calm slash jenna
julie and get started and download the
free headspace app guys i'm telling you
you will be hard-pressed to find
something as good as that and as
convenient and easy to use
also as effective as the headspace app
so thank you to headspace response for
the podcast guys coach at thank you
sponsors you know what just totally
sidebar when you're talking about that I
was thinking the other night that I
wanted to look it up when I was little I
had a cassette tape that I bought at
this store down the street from where I
lived that was called the angel shop and
they would sell all these little like
angels and like little figurines and
like just weird angel stuff and I bought
a cassette tape from there that was just
a woman speaking with like some rain
sounds it was like it sounded like a
cigar and I would put my put it in my
Walkman and fall asleep to it and she
would talk to you about your guardian
angels and where they are and what
they're doing and that you imagine
yourself like sliding down a rainbow
with your guardian angel and stuff it
was really adorable that's sweet yeah it
was but it was like doing guided
meditations sort of but not really
virgin and headset I wouldn't call it
meditating but every single night I
wanted to listen to that it was like the
best like even if you did that like app
or something like that you're like I
want to take ten minutes and just listen
to this yeah I mean it's like if you did
time it's a great way to turn on it's
incredible like go to sleep - um yeah
that's that's funny I like that sorry
thank you it's cute
all right enough about you back to the
nuclear winter I love you okay um we
have to narrow down ten people that we
definitely want to take with us we are
both going to be in this so this is like
we don't each have our pick this is a
dual pick we got a we gotta figure it
out so definitely the marine right off
the bat lean with all the supplies
that's a no-brainer so the person
congratulations to person number one the
Marines just complete given the Marine
that has a truck full of guns food water
and other supplies that they will I mean
think of a more tailor-made perfect
answer but it's our first person it rise
you're good
yes now we need to debate we're keeping
so in a bomb shelter you like some
people who are good with like materials
that you can find anywhere right like
the botanists the mechanic like what
what do their deals again okay so well
yeah the most important people like the
doctor like we really need a doctor
doctor but he's triggered in
claustrophobic situations the nurse yeah
we could take the doctor or the nurse
because it's like they've immerse
there's four puppies that they'll bring
with that but the nurse is not a doctor
like they don't have the skills a doctor
I mean they still go to medical school
that's just saying you know that's true
they go to medical but the there's a
reason that they're a nurse not a doctor
they haven't put in the time the years
and years years of apprenticeship for
whatever to get to being a doctor so in
the bomb shelter no they can't because
they're in a bomb shelter not Medical
School good try though
residents I'm trying to think of like in
a situation when you're in a bomb
shelter what are some typical injuries
that a person who is in a bomb shelter
that cannot leave would have maybe a
blast injuries blast wounds yeah right
things like that radiation radiation
cause I'm just scared of a nurse trying
to treat all that like that's something
a doctor should treat a nurse while they
are very ja fire-type doctor is gonna be
claustrophobic the whole time what we
can drink are you can leave like a
corner a big space Ecore nur of a bomb
shelter just for the doctor and no one
can everyone that corner and what is
this what is triggered mean we can just
give the doctor some headspace we don't
have we don't have headspace because the
only app on our phone is musically okay
that was not established you're right
you're right um I think I'm I'm in favor
the doctor I wouldn't want to get like a
nice desert or puppies
that's for puppy you have to feed so
they're so fun and companionship and all
that but you have to feed for extra
that's that you're feeding you could eat
for pumpkin ham with them are young so
you say doctor over nurse I mean as much
as cute puppies are great and as much as
nurses are amazing and hugely necessary
to the world on a daily basis I'm gonna
go with doctor I'm afraid that there are
going to be things that a nurse cannot
help with where a doctor could and the
puppies are just extra mouths you have
to feed yeah but they're so change we're
going with the doctor all right
nurses out nurses out doctors and
because we need the dog doctor is in
alright
Fox [ __ ] say okay so we got marina
doctor we got to think of like well the
marine probably is good at building [ __ ]
with what he has he also has supplies so
maybe we don't need like a like the
architect or the mechanic because we
have the marine with his so the mechanic
is a [ __ ] pedophile I know which
wouldn't be a problem if we didn't take
the pregnant woman or the orphan or the
musically
assuming that the musically star is
likely a child okay let's buy - lets we
definitely want the lawyer either he
rapes people what but like what about
the chef that chews with their mouth
open that's a kind of a chef is someone
that we'd really like to have true but
let's we should we should get we gotta
get all the people that we need first I
feel like we're doing that no the lawyer
is a raid we don't need a lawyer
regardless it's a lawyer why would we
need a lawyer in a bomb shelter no it's
very true but I mean they're smart they
are smart but they're also someone who
has sex with people when they say no
they're out they're out
goodbye oh boy Tyler shouldn't make
people what if we got doctor and rapist
and nurse and pedophile that'd be fun
we'd be funny but I'll die of all
meetings okay um the teacher or the
police officer about these people is
architect let's organize these okay the
rocket scientists is someone who won't
stop asking you to subscribe to they
should take
we should take them I mean that's pretty
valuable because we're gonna be annoyed
but we're gonna be annoyed anyway from
everything else like no more spots we
gotta be careful here rocket scientists
they could also be annoying as [ __ ] they
are annoying they ask you to subscribe
to the YouTube channel but to be
perfectly honest if a rocket scientist
had a youtube channel I would probably
want to subscribe to it and also once
you subscribe to it they they might not
stop asking or no they don't they never
stop have they never stopped asking well
we're kind of accustomed to seeing
people non-stop ask people to subscribe
anyway it's like survivor like sometimes
just cuz you're really smart great
doesn't really mean that we want to live
with you that's true it's a good point
let's let's put that off okay
the architect has a Mensa brain oh yeah
we should take him
she's probably annoying in the Sun but
we should take him yeah we should take
him or just take you so so far we have
the marine with all the supplies the
doctor who's triggered in tight
situations and the architect who has a
Mensa prayer who we're gonna try to calm
down all the time
I will hold off on that the all right
I'm sorry
at least your birthday will be going on
the mayor who's currently heavily
addicted to that okay so who was it
would come running going through
withdrawals you know I agree and he's he
sounds like he's corrupt as is and has
no regard for his job title and that he
probably shouldn't be using meth regular
yeah no no I'm gonna say no because he's
probably a real [ __ ] he sounds like
an [ __ ] he's in a position of power
and he's like a complete drug addict
that's not cool not what's not cool like
that's not all right he's out the mayor
is out good you good yeah he's out good
bye what about the sexy pregnant woman
can we talk about her I feel like she's
a dark horse that we're gonna leave to
the side for right now okay matter cuz
she's sexy I mean so am i but we have
really affection really like I
underlined again um what's the deal with
the chef he chooses an awesome mouth
open okay or the bomb shelters that
shit's gonna echo and AH mechanic that's
a pedophile I don't think we yeah
I mean what are we gonna need a mechanic
for that architect and I'm orangutan
your honor or we don't have the rocket
scientist we don't have the artisan
architect the architect in the marine
could probably like we have no cars
you're gonna work on we're in a bomb
shelter like what what like seriously
what could a mechanic MacGyver down
there that could somehow help us I mean
you never know but no I'm asking and
asking seriously I don't know I don't
have an answer for that what could he
could he somehow engineer a way to like
dig a different way out of the bomb
shelter that's not the way we're not
trying to dig our way out we're trying
to live in it stay in there or we're
trying to find a path to a place that we
couldn't get before that's not the point
of a bomb shelter well the point of a
bomb shelter is to shelter yourself from
a nuclear winter so you have no need to
ever get
that's really ok alright new nuke drops
and you're in your bomb shelter
eventually you want to leave no you live
there for like 20 years and then you
leave until the radiation when you leave
you got to think about what's gonna
happen then just saying no yeah but you
don't have to tunnel your way out
there's a way in and a way out
yes but what if the Wayne and the way
out is like completely dumped with
bodies or [ __ ] aliens I don't need a
mechanic to help you get out I'm just
I'm just posing the question ok Wow
generally doesn't like mechanics does
the felons deal again the convicted
felon also thinks he's a psychic
or shoes that sounds annoying handing I
think that there is psychic that sounds
kind of productive on like five
different levels now you kill people and
he thinks he's a psychic or she hmm this
person is an unstable we can't we just
can't why I got to be a guy we can't
have you
what's the orphans deal um the orphan
percent okay see that is something that
I might actually want in my life like
you have zero entertainment and there's
a little child know but there's also
like you know you can't be a seven year
old doctor this is a young person we
need younger people to I'll live us in
case we have terrible radiation
poisoning but I do they forever pretend
they're cat so like yeah they're like 40
yes let's take that so chemically no
this is on the maybe pile of in any
minute we have to get all of our like
our hard things out alright well
knowledge knowledge teacher okay see got
the teacher has scissors reading okay
here's my thing at this I don't think
this is necessarily bad it's not bad my
hands is like my favorite and he's so
nice yeah so I mean if she's like that I
don't really see I also teach tolerance
to deal with like people that are
different than you who is that teaching
tolerance to the seven-year-old cat yeah
I like the teacher with says I think she
provides character to the group she uh
you know alright but we giving her a
spot though I see maybe but I'm
Cheikh also give us haircuts okay yes
yes and she has scissors like that's a
huge variable but she also can't like do
it so she has the knowledge she can
teach us and we'll do the rest
mm-hmm and she'll give everyone haircuts
for free haircuts freely right sweet
tonight four out of ten marine doctor
architect teacher mm-hmm all right sweet
um the botanist that is a violent severe
and violent oh but here's the thing
though if we're gonna be trying to grow
anything down there they might be very
helpful yeah and like the withdrawals
will last for maybe like a couple days a
week at most and then and no that is not
true alcohol is the one term so explain
how long do our all what is a withdrawal
it depends how severe right so if they
die we throw them out whatever but then
we've wasted a spot
yeah but they I mean we have a [ __ ]
seven-year-old cat so like the spaces
aren't super side that yet that's true
um let's keep him in the maybe pile and
just because I feel like hell
I feel like if he in any event he
survives his withdrawal right and it
doesn't like kill another person we have
a botanist well how do you know that
he's not going to grow fruit ferment it
and get [ __ ] loaded on it all the
time if he's if he's a raging alcoholic
that process is way too slow for his
addiction but like fermenting alcohol
you're gonna be in a bomb shelter for
twenty years and there's no alcohol down
there plus we haven't established that
there's no alcohol in the bomb shelter
shelter if you're that much of an addict
but if he's a functional alcoholic let
him ferment the fruit and get drunk then
he's a functioning person had everybody
Oh is he in violence yeah let's keep
them in the Navy pile we may be able to
work with this okay the teacher mrs. R
so here's the box you're gonna hit the
teacher with scissors for you you'll get
[ __ ] up here's the thing we can't have
them count any time if I'm really in the
shelter which I am yeah I'm gonna go to
the botanist and be like hey bro we'll
be friends alright I'll sneak you some
alcohol I'll figure it out hold on how
you gonna expose in group to risk nine
it'll be fine because we're cool and I'm
bigger than him and he doesn't you don't
manage it you don't reach it to you
don't know any of that he probably
should he's probably a black oh he
bought kill everyone hey I'm gonna go
befriend him and give him alcohol make
him happy and then learn as much as I
possibly can about basic botany skills
and then teacher kill him let the
teacher cut him up a little bit oh my
god and then we have a new botanist a
new botanist okay I feel like you could
absorb information for the I feel like
botany is like I must have in a bomb
shelter your [ __ ] bomb shelter you
need bomb but what's really gonna grow
in there like we don't have the supplies
you grab some soils [ __ ] put it down
there and figure it out [ __ ] what's
doctor mean absolutely no farmed on the
moon on Mars okay I didn't see that
movie at all to grab soil you're in a
shelter option Marcia Kramer Julian this
episode of general Park ass I hate to
the point of the shelter is that you're
not exposed to anything but the shelter
itself one you can't just like go grab
some soil alright so well somehow we fit
a truck down there cuz the marine just
brought his truck
it's just supplies ok so there's got to
be something he can alter okay
our Sarna whether it's like a MRE right
or something whatever there's something
that you can grow [ __ ] with okay okay
well alright here's one other thing if
he's that much of a drunk no what makes
you so confident that he can actually
teach you anything about botany
he's a functioning alcoholic we didn't
decide that he is a severe and violent
alcoholic what if he decides I was ready
like plants grow no waters um we wrote
severe and violent alcoholic alright can
we keep him in the maybe and decide
later I like the botanist now a peeper
maybe
alright let's decide on the police
officer police officer who masturbates
no no less it does no but he's trained
and skilled or she or she much prefer a
semen
meaning interested and a guy actually
that'd be really loud girls are I think
they're both there's no upset there's no
winning with this card right now mouth
yeah how come you can't do that in a
pond definitely not okay like where
there's clearly like maybe only one big
jam room get out eight times a day every
day get out get out
now goodbye that's a no confine I don't
care if it's like the hottest pregnant
woman okay we go masters good yeah I'm
not guess she might just slide in here
okay
yes you might just be left over yeah
okay with the masseuse what's their deal
um the masseuse makes an offensive
amount of the offering officer yes I
mean imagine imagine even your
relaxation of getting massage all the
time down like you're at a bomb shelter
you're like am i of on Twitter and I
don't resort yes person what is your she
I can't tell I'm getting massages
everyday moving about you and saying you
know little time people that is my bet
is literally my heaven that's when I die
and go to heaven
someone massaging me in making options
bronzes PIPA oh that's so relaxing when
you say office stuff PIPA ah PIPA what's
your daughter's name P P I mean this
person isn't absolutely no so that's it
I will not give you a heart no I'm sorry
I will not agree tonight so maybe pile
yes you're in a bomb shelter and someone
is trained professionally and massaging
you that is the most single most
stressful situation you can ever be in
nuclear winter and someone's there being
like hey what can I work on you today
your upper back and what about your legs
your shoulders what hurts let me fix it
while I make jokes about the best show
ever created so you can have great like
memories of the most amazing pass time
when life existed put them in the
shelter they're amazing
really alright this is your pick I'll
give you your pick all right I'll take
the masu right you get the masseuse see
the masseuse where's last time you had a
massage that shit's [ __ ] amazing
it hurts oh my god
it's that's probably cuz they weren't
making office Reverend sister relax
you're not that's five we're halfway
there we have the Marine the doctor the
architect the teacher in the masseuse
and this person has scissors for hands
yeah but we're going to learn so much
dude it's like schools in session all
the time how can you imagine if she was
your arts and crafts teacher six fan
okay let's I think we have one the okay
we can make a decision on them the horse
that won that won't stop lighting their
own fights
okay here's why here's why that could
happen now here because he's fine no he
clearly has a means of lighting fire he
has to have a lighter or a match which
could be used in other districts like
you said with the botanist we've clearly
already sort of prepped this shelter to
have somewhere to grow food and food to
grow so clearly we would have a [ __ ]
down starting fire I mean in terms of
like entertainment that's like that's
top-notch [ __ ] in terms of functionality
and well-being that's the worst possible
scenario it's like when he stands up
feel Highness your head and he just
burns all your hair off all the time and
your eyebrows all gone he could light
the whole bomb shelter on it was like
what would happen though if he lit the
doctor on fire with this fart and the
doctor can't treat himself who's gonna
treat him let's keep him in the maybe
maybe maybe five guys good okay let's do
uh homeless person Kumbaya I'm pretty
sure no that's gonna smell and be
annoying the home you don't know that
homeless person insists on having a
guitar kumbaya sing-along every night
for a bit I think after three nights
this person would be dead to me I can't
maybe dead IRL I'd kill them guitar I
cannot no no I'm gonna have to say
bye-bye to you I'm very sorry you're not
coming in no you're not and leave your
guitar oh yeah
while you're at it um okay here's a good
one the ventriloquist who is a veteran
zombie premise Sambi prepper like that's
pretty damn helpful but they're a
[ __ ] ventriloquist it's so annoying
okay but you're literally in a bomb
shelter with nothing you know have your
phone except for the musically so that's
our show every night show but is that
better or worse than a guitar kumbaya
every night so much better
you think so could you tell him to sob
kind of stuff because the kumbaya guy
thinks he's actually like being
spiritual and helpful well really he's
right we wanted to gather Oh God
he's like the bad Ron on Parks and Rec I
do not want that guy I say yes to the
veteran zombie prepper yes that's such a
huge feature and you know the
ventriloquist thing like there might be
other uses for for that skill other than
just performing like like he's clearly
really good with his mouth hand-eye
coordinate and mouth coordination you
never know where that's going to come in
handy sounded really dirty when I said
that I didn't mean it like that right we
got he's a guy he's a great economist we
got six all right just a review
ventriloquist who is a veteran zombie
prepper marine with all the supplies
doctor who gets claustrophobic and
triggered architect who has a Mensa
brain teacher who has scissors for hands
and a masseuse who makes an offensive
amount of office references every single
day all right some if four more how many
are not the maybe pile yet are they
making issue okay a pregnant woman that
is really sexy definitely definitely a
pop star this person is like the real
okay the pop star size complaints and
says well what are we gonna do now oh
and every no version of that no room for
that but they could sing for us or can
they know they're busy asking what they
have to do anyone who is gonna say that
sentence ever let alone every single
time that they talk what are we gonna do
now plus we also can't assume that since
she's a pop star or he's a pop star that
they actually have any vocal abilities
for music a pop star does not
necessarily have
absolutely I say no you know I'm with
you
goodbye goodbye we have four spots bye
yeah we have all right so the musically
person that has a two invisible friends
we basically get rid of three yes we
have to get rid of either the rocket
scientist who doesn't stop asking okay
the rocket scientists that doesn't stop
asking you to subscribe to the YouTube
channel is really not the worst here's
why I like them because that they
actually have a youtube channel useful
they're useful but they're also like not
completely ancient schooled rocket
science like they're clearly in touch
with the internet and the new-age so
they're not annoying right even though
the internet was just destroyed doesn't
matter
then it's the knowledge and the way they
act life that they were used to I say we
take earth keep the rocket scientists so
now we have seven I'm gonna say no to
the horse what why please leave it leave
the horse maybe pal
um the chef's that choose with their
mouth open not the worst that's kind of
Awesome but I'm only winning in an age
where the entire family is dead and
everyone you ever met in your life is
dad in the whole world is ended
that's like not a problem any kid hey
cook cook but like we only have a
limited food supply do we even really
need a chef I mean if you have like
limited food supply a chef is the most
important thing cause he's gonna make
that limited food taste so much better
than a wooden yeah maybe know better how
to ration our food yeah and also
probably he can like be a second teacher
and help us with our nutrition I say we
take all right we'll keep the ships I
agree okay so YouTube's knots all right
for a woman right now we have a really
sexy pregnant woman a horse that likes
its own farts on fire
musically start with to make-believe
friends he severe and violent alcoholic
botanist and a seven-year-old orphan
that pretends they're a cat here's why I
think we need the botanist no I just
make an argument why don't we just cut
to the chase and keep the really sexy
magnet when at some point we are going
to run out of food we need to be able to
cultivate food
we have to or else we're all gonna die
we have a zero tolerance policy for
violence in this shelter you'd be dead
you don't have a zero tolerance policy
its policy for anything if you're dead
you'd starve to death he's the one who's
going to keep everyone alive if we can
everyone can team up and be like how do
we keep this alcoholic from punching
everyone and functioning how do we give
them enough alcohol to function and how
to limit him to what if he decides that
he's pissed off and he like snapped it
reserves it supplies drunk or she's
dropped to take one he creates food when
they create food you make it so that you
have eyes on them so they can't just
[ __ ] wreak havoc you like you have to
get drunk and create a fight that didn't
even happen and decide that they're not
gonna grow any food for anybody anyone
that's not a problem because that whole
that whole scenario you just described
wouldn't have existed because everyone
would be dead without him
pancha a botanist is unless they're like
a [ __ ] child rapist I have to take a
botanist all right fine then we only
have one more spot here he's your
problem Oh or she your problems I gotta
be a guy you I just said or she why you
gotta be a girl the botanist that is a
severe alcoholic yeah enjoy enjoy your
potatoes every night that you dick up
here doubt of the no that was your
argument to keep the chef is that the
chef will know how to make that these
two together we're gonna be eating
[ __ ] gourmet [ __ ] yeah who's gonna
get their mouth open and the other one's
gonna punch that one in the face it'll
be terrible oh my god we're gonna eat so
well
I'm like excited for dinner and I know
mm-hmm the teacher with scissors for
hands okay make sure she's all right for
us he can we just get rid of the
musically person they're gonna annoy the
[ __ ] out of right the one that has two
invisible friends named like periwinkle
delay they're crowding our space all
right two invisible friends and their
music and they already used our
emergency phone to make them musically
and then ask everyone in the room why it
didn't post yeah and I and also got mad
at everyone because there were no legs
on it because everyone in the world
Deb and what the Wi-Fi password is [ __ ]
them okay we have a horse the only one
spot left right yeah but the choice is
pretty clear all right
you know horse that one no sexy-ass
pregnant women yeah but what about the
seven-year-old or you're always talking
about cat you're always okay here's
here's my argument do we want a sexy
pregnant woman who's sexy will be
pregnant have the kid and continue to be
sexy likely and have a young child who
is probably also a good-looking person
when they grow up or do you want a kid
that acts like a cat for the rest of
their life it's cute for now but not
when they're 30
no no in there like anything about 15
that shit's annoying hmm right I mean
think of it so we're keeping the sexy
pregnant woman and she's having a baby
so that's a another kernel cheer we get
husband and then we get another mouth to
feed which you said was on existing
mouth to feed how do you know cuz she's
sexy he's falling on his head so the but
then we have 13 people in our bomb
shelter that's an unlucky number
yeah us too yeah Oh
unlucky out the whole world is already
obliterated what much worse luck can you
have but you said we couldn't have four
puppies one baby compared to four
puppies you're not gonna eat nearly as
much as those giant dogs and um how do
you know they're not for chihuahuas
doesn't [ __ ] matter because the moms
gonna die and the kid's gonna survive
eventually all right yeah and she's sexy
ah yeah are you jealous that I like the
sexy pregnant women Jenna no no no I
think she's specially to she's really
really all right so let's go over I find
a list all right all right so we're
saying goodbye to a [ __ ] horse thanks I
don't want your cyber farts on my
[ __ ] bong shelter oh but it could
have been so great it's funny but then
you have a fire farting horse in your
mom's butt we can write em we're just in
tiny circles lighting everyone by
I saw I saw a video of a horse like kick
someone when they came up and startled
them and that shit's [ __ ] brutal you
know it's terrifying and we also we said
goodbye to the 7 year old orphans and
pretends we love you but sorry no cats
ah alright who do we got left read your
5 and I'll remind the Marine who has a
truck full of guns food water and other
supplies that they will bring you're in
the shelter the doctor who is triggered
in claustrophobic situations is in our
shelter the architect who has a Mensa
brain is so clearly in our shelter and
not problematic by comparison the
teacher who has scissors for hands is in
our shelter and the masseuse who makes
an offensive amount of the office
references in a day is in our [ __ ]
shelter also in our shelter is a chef
who chews with his mouth or her mouth
open a pregnant woman who is really sexy
we are rocket scientists who will not
stop asking you to subscribe to their
YouTube channel a botanist who is a
severe and violent raging alcoholic and
a ventriloquist who is a veteran zombie
prepper I would say we did ok and we'll
probably live a decently long time
considering the resources we have in the
people we picked I think we did good
yeah but that [ __ ] violent drunk is
gonna kill us all no we have a Marine he
can handle him ok he's got a gun he's
just [ __ ] about the gun do you know
could I kill them really quickly is the
horse that farts fire yeah that would
have been a disaster it would have been
amazing yeah enjoy having [ __ ] fiery
dead people because you're even cook our
food with this [ __ ] yeah all this food
smells so good and then this [ __ ]
horse fire farting and it suddenly isn't
so damn appetizing it's funny until
you're hungry and your food is fart
right right when you go to sleep he's
like
I love you baby good night
oh you're lit on fire by a fart good
night you're dead wow that was a great
way to die Wow if you could get over the
smell the concert you could get over
this yeah [ __ ] right I'm not getting
over that smell okay all out all [ __ ]
off myself I'm going up to the radiation
buy any more dark and close like bomb
shelter and it smells like horse farts
lit on fire
any dump so literally drowned in his
[ __ ] in like a woman but he's such a
good friend
oh and you can write and can't argue
with that
[ __ ] you and she just like [ __ ] all over
the room as far as what okay again think
about this phone he would have no tail
because only been gone so but it got
like lit on fire a long time ago okay
I'm so glad we don't have a fire
fighting horse goodbye horse I think we
did get that this was fun this was
really fun this is thank you sanely fun
our friend of our from for suggesting
this game this is brilliant we love
games like this for the podcast if you
guys have any games this is what
suggestions we will absolutely read the
comments and and hop on and do the game
because this was great well I imagine
anytime you play this it's completely
different that's true you can I can play
this again - we could do round juice is
really [ __ ] fun um but thanks for
tuning in guys are tuning guys you want
to be with you as much as we have fun
with there guess it was fun I know we on
the podcast we do get carried away like
excited to have guests on believe we
also really cherish the time just having
our Dan Jay podcast this is [ __ ] dope
this is done ideally you guys enjoyed it
thank you headspace for sponsoring the
podcast guys go check out headspace comm
slash Jenna Julianne download the free
app and ten ten days of free guided
meditations links are in the description
also with Poland branch that's bol and
branch comm promo code Jenna Julianne 22
sponsors thank you to sponsors guys go
check them out they make the show
completely free for you guys today
also we are currently in the process
getting the podcast on other platforms
soar like Spotify things like that
so we are working on it we are in the
process we've heard you guys that you
want to listen on those things we are
working on it so just so you know you
are being heard
also happy fourth of July there is
currently a sale on our merch store
right now there is jenna julienne
podcast our and click merge thursday and
we are July freedom sale for you
freedom sales or trade deals all sorts
an awesome merch the sweet Kermit shirts
everything you guys might want they are
on sale right now due to the 4th try so
go check them out yeah we love you guys
pretty much as fun as that was it was
really fun right I'll see you guys next
week bye